this is a production of Cornell
University
thank you for inviting me to talk today
I'll just give you a little bit of
background history so branching out is
the IPM newsletter for trees and shrubs
and it covers insects and diseases of
woody plants so we publish every two
weeks from April through June and every
three weeks from july through September
so we tried to provide timely
information on all aspects of pest
management on woody ornamentals the
newsletter itself was started by dr.
George Hudler in the plant pathology
department at Cornell in 1994 as a
master's project for one of his graduate
students I came on board in July of 1996
and for those of you who can do math yes
that is 20 years of writing branching
out so and so you may have heard that
George has retired in January of this
year but he is still working with me on
the branching out newsletter as the
co-editor and he says he will continue
to do that for as long as I'd like to
continue to do it so our target audience
for the newsletter is tree care
professionals so arborist and golf
course superintendents and urban
foresters and that sort and our goal is
to inform these pests managers on the
progress of insect and my diseases on
woody ornamentals and the new york state
area and to a lesser degree we cover
currencies of symptoms of non-infectious
plant problems to such as freezing
injury and winter drying and drought so
the way we do but was we gather all this
information by a combination of on-site
scouting and reports from other
contributors to help us prepare the
articles about the test so and we gather
the all the observations and we prepare
them into a commentary about the
subsequent life stages of the past and
then scouting tips that might be helpful
and preventive or curative actions and
management alternatives as well what I
do is I drive down a mix of different
places that I go sigh Sarah I Drive down
state to Long Island and I visit various
sites and county extension office's then
I return back to Ithaca and but along
the route i make predetermined stops at
orange westchester and nassau county's
on each of our trips so so this is our
one of our stops we stopped at the at
farmingdale College in Nassau County I'm
also i also stopped at Hofstra
University when I'm down there and
planting fields Arboretum as well so
it's not too terrible planting fields
you may recognize that's a very famous
up site that's often taken photos of
planting field and then one of the other
sites we stopped at was we I go to a
cemetery in Westchester County scouting
in the cemetery some cemeteries are very
barren but this particular one has a
nice mix of trees and shrubs and luckily
they don't treat anything so that's good
for me another day of the week I go to
the western part of New York State I go
to Finger Lakes Community College which
has a nice little Arboretum there and
that's in Wayne County and then I also
go to highland park in Monroe County so
and I revisit these specific sites in
this state so that's the same sites all
the time so I have an idea of what i'm
looking for each spot but you know i get
surprises all the time and just keep it
an eye out for things that aren't
looking good if seeing a little
off-color little browning or something
and or you know sometimes I'm looking
and I'm seeing a lot of maybe answer
flies or or something and I'm like oh
there's a lot of honeydew over there
what's happening with that plant so so
by revisiting these specific sites and
doing the on-site scouting I can keep it
good you know
monitoring those pest populations on a
regular basis and can keep a good eye
out for that and then we then I also
have several sites in the area that I
scout on including my own property which
is an abandoned Christmas tree farm so
when my husband I bought that property
eight years ago George asked me if we
had paid extra because of all the great
diseases I told them that we have on our
property so he was thrilled to hear that
we had a nice infection of pine pine
gall rust and white pine blister rust
and variety of other nice conifer
diseases and insects as well I pretty
much we could do a scouting trip right
to my property so in addition to my own
on-site scouting i also have Cornell
Cooperative Extension agent that
handsome arborist that helped contribute
observations for the scouting report
section as well and that helps kind of
give a nice little snapshot of pest
populations in the entire state at any
given time so that's that's how it's
done so the newsletter itself in each
issue we in addition to the scouting
report we include a feature article and
that gives us an opportunity to address
a particular pest or other topic in more
detail than we can in the other columns
so in the last several years we've been
able to upgrade and include color photos
and the scouting reports as well as the
feature article thanks to some generous
donations from arborist and such and we
also include growing degree days and
phonology in each issue and we try to
keep that the text pretty easy to read
and just the right length to cover each
topic we know the tree care
professionals out there are really busy
and they just looking for a quick
snapshot they need to know what do they
need to look for this week you know they
don't they don't have a lot of time to
you know read a ton of text and so we
try to boil it down to just the
essentials ok this is what they need
and they can just look at that or share
with their staff and go right out there
and use that information so I'd say one
of the things this season we hope to do
is something new George would like make
some videos which then we would linked
from a QR code that we would include in
the newsletter so any of you know George
you know that he's quite the Entertainer
this is jen i do one did want to say
that we take those those centerfold so
whatever you call them and we post them
in our diagnostic lab they're great
reading so when volunteers have you know
a little bit of time they can peruse
that you know and it's very helpful
because I think that what comes in often
reflects that that that list so yeah
that's what we're kind of hoping is
gross that's a reflection of what's
going on out there and so and we go
downstate to scout because really
they're often a week or more ahead of
the rest of New York State especially up
there in central New York or a little
farther north so we know it worth our
time to go down there and to get that
scouting information because they're a
bit ahead so often what we'll see you
last week in Long Island is just
happening this week and you know parts
farther north of New York State okay so
here's that just quick look at our
website pretty simple basic but it's got
information so about subscription
information you can also look at back
issues if you're not familiar with the
newsletter we've got back issues here
idea of what the newsletter includes
it's that breaking out self-supporting
through subscription charges and
donations and the normal charge for the
subscription is fifty dollars but as
cornell cooperative extension educators
you can get a electronic access to
branching out for no charge so you just
have to send me an email and you can
contact us my email address is on there
and send us an email and i would email
you
password information you need for the
2016 season and it changes every year
and if you know yet if you're willing to
help spread the word about branching out
we can provide you with subscription
forms so you can have available at your
County offices to share with to bring to
the attention of tree care professionals
in your county so right now we have
about 400 subscribers including some big
names like the Smithsonian and longwood
gardens and Paul Smith's college and
they the Georgia bear readers are from
New York State or the New England states
but we have a handful from other states
including Ohio and Michigan and Illinois
addition to the newsletter we also
published a book so it's a 150 updated
feature articles it's about 300 page
book and that is thirty-five dollars
which is to kind of finish up I think
some of the things that we were really
noticing this season that seems some of
the highlights our winter injury we're
seeing a lot of desiccation on spruce
and troopers this spring so we had a
nice article in the last issue in issue
number three Sandra Jensen from the
diagnostic lab wrote a nice article all
about the desiccation on conifers and so
that we're getting a bunch of questions
on and right now what we're seeing out
in the field as this is a time season
for different for us to be sporulating
so there's lots of cedar roster out
there and their full glory and white
pine blister rust is check on it just
finishing up but we've got pine pine
gall rust coming and from Don gable
death on in the Botanic Garden in New
Orca said that he thinks it's going to
be a banner year for cedar rust from
what he was seeing so and then the other
interesting tidbit was we got a report
from Long Island that box of leaf miner
was emerging rather early this year so
it's really a couple
weeks earlier than we expected but it
came from a very reliable source and he
even saw the pupil cases so we're sure
that you know is what he's seeing but so
we're um so I had a conversation with
dan gilleon and we were both surprised
that it was coming out a little early
but we've always include that in this
week's scouting report and that's the
source stuff that we like to put in
things that are you know maybe slightly
unusual and so we do welcome anything
that's you know happening in your county
we'd love to hear any information
especially if you've got outbreak
situation of something we'd like to
share that with our readers so they know
what's going on in the state and it's
nice for us because we can't be
everywhere oh I scout in many places
it's really just a snapshot in time and
i can't i can't go to all the sites in
new york state but so anything that if
you you know if you're what if you'd
like to share with us we'd be willing to
take any information that you have to
share so i'm sure you've all seen the
problems with blue spruce that continues
there are no way there's no one answer
unfortunately for on that one but so
we're kind of keeping an eye on seeing
what's happening with the blue spruce
this season it's been kind of a problem
for the last couple of years i know many
of you have seen that as well and and
we're seeing down in the lower hudson
valley a lot more is it spruce bud go
Mitch then yes I suspect we've been
seeing it for a while and we didn't know
what we were looking at we were finding
all kinds of other things as well and
that was good enough you know what I
mean in a sense you're saying oh it's
got this and it's got that now that
we're looking for it we're finding it in
a lot of spruce samples Norway spruce
okay yeah yeah we were you know we've
put a little bit of information about
that and the newsletter a couple does
the last couple of years Dan Gilmore has
been very helpful with that thank you
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu